li s est qu'il est président de l'union
des musulmans de levallois monsieur s
est qu'ils bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une
première réaction à cette attaque
tout d'abord mais les sincères
condoléances à aux victimes de cet
odieux attentat à toute leur famille au
et surtout offert aux soeurs delà de la
communauté catholique de france monsieur
est celle qui est ce que vous comprenez
toutes ces voix qui s'élèvent et qui
demande aux musulmans de france de
condamner ces actes terroristes alors
moi je vais répondre en tant qu' en tant
que français de confession musulmane
toutes ces voix qui lui demande de
condamner les biens les bien sûr qu'on
condamne mais bien sûr qu'on condamne on
condamne n'importe quel acte odieux qui
touchent notre pays qui touche notre
france on les condamne dans les condamne
d'une d'une fermeté inouï
ça n'a rien à voir mais totalement rien
à voir avec l'islam
et si ces personnes connaissaient un peu
l'islam et la relation d'amour qui
existe entre le christianisme et l'islam
jamais il ne se comporterait de cette
manière là ce que vous voulez dire c'est
que vous condamnez mais tout d'abord en
tant que français mais je condamne en
tant qu' en tant que français de
confession musulmane madame monsieur est
celle que j'appelle président de l'union
des musulmans de le voilà je voulais
savoir de ballons de levallois est ce
que vous avez écouté entendu le discours
d' emmanuel macron à l'instant à nice
écoutez j'ai pas j'ai pas eu l'occasion
d'écouter le discours des maquis des
manuels macron parce que j'étais sur mon
lieu de travail
mais il faut savoir que quand un acte
est perpétrée en france mais partout
dans le monde avec cette étiquette
d'islam entre guillemets on est on est
complètement alors complètement au delà
d'être ko groggy mois depuis et depuis
depuis ce matin depuis cette annonce g
une boule au ventre il ya il ya voilà là
oui on demande
on demande à l'état de deux paires
indiqué est de s'occuper de ces gens-là
de ces terroristes de ces barbares ils
ont pas leur place en france monsieur et
c'est qu'ils merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france je rappelle êtes
président de l'union des musulmans de
levallois merci à vous